you've proven yourselves by the amount
of followers you have
those are valuable in a way that so many
people
don't understand you get up in the
morning you're no longer number one
your investors are number one you're
down here and until they get their money
back and then some
you're still down here and people say
that's outrageous i mean why am i giving
you 9.8
of the company i said because i'm mr
wonderful and you're not
so let's talk about what happened in the
last year basically
you're a monster on tick tock and now
you have a fund
that you're managing keep passing
how the hell did that happen for me from
the beginning of
time i've been a hustler and an
entrepreneur like i was a 12 year old
kid that
was playing sports and every time i went
to my tournaments i had a hockey shirt
company so i was bringing
like hundreds of t-shirts and selling
them to the other teams and i was like
having a social media account for my uh
my businesses as well when i was like 12
13
i just found something so interesting
about like instagram and how you could
have these videos go viral so i would
make sports accounts and then sell
through my sports accounts the merch and
then i would start a lacrosse company
dyeing mesh
wax coating it so like kids sticks
wouldn't uh
start performing inconsistently when it
rained outside so it was just always
something that i was really passionate
about and then
when i had the opportunity to come out
to la for the first time i met michael
and we started talking about the
industry i just have done a tour with
griffin completely got ripped off the
tour manager ran away with the money
i got like 750 bucks i think griff might
have got a thousand dollars
tour made over a million i'm sitting
here seeing my friends get ripped off
myself and how this industry has no one
protecting there's no wme caa uta
signing
tick tockers like they are today so we
decided to go found
talonx which was the management company
that went and signed a hundred top tick
talkers
and my entire goal and mission there was
to finally bring
uh a sense of safety to the social media
world
within tech talk so you your structure
what you've done now
is you know to say okay if i'm going to
monetize this if i can build it into a
business i'm going to play by the
mainstream rules
you got an agent you have a fund with
compliance
you've got people investing in it one
thing i would say though for guys your
age
you take dough from people that's a
whole new
thing that's a huge responsibility
because
for all the optimism you've got fund
management's real tough there's no
question but you do have an advantage
you know where to deploy capital in a
very very early stage just on what you
know is going on out there
given that you're and do you do what you
do but
i've been doing this for a long time and
what i've learned is it's very sobering
you get up in the morning you're no
longer number one
your investors are number one you're
down here yeah and until they get their
money back and then some
you're still down here and then after
they've got their money back you're
still down here because you're raising
more money exactly right
next month so you're now going to be
subservient for the rest of your lives
in a cool way because not many people
get to run a find
but you ain't number one you get it
right
no 100 this is serious this is work like
if you they think you know something
they don't know right they're putting
their trust in you too right so
you you need to earn that you just show
them that you respect that as well
here's how the conversation goes for me
you may want to think about this
hi kevin would you put half a million
dollars in my deal
if we're just starting out here here's
what it looks like why do you want 500
000 from me oh well we really like to
tap into your social base and all the
investors you have already all around
the world
i said yeah that sounds good um and they
say well
our last round was 5 million free money
i said oh it's interesting
they said well you want to do it i say
no here's what i'm going to do
i'm going to make you an offer you don't
have to take it but you can think about
it
and i don't negotiate you're going to
give me 12 and a half percent of the
founders shares
i said give me all right for free
and they're going to be locked up over a
long period of time because i'm going to
insist that we work together for at
least three years so i'm happy to go
into a lock-up
then every round that you raise at
whatever market valuation it is
i will participate i will fund
my pro-rated position of my 12 and a
half shares and why is it 12 and a half
because after the option pool
is put in place for the employees it's
going to drop down to 9.8
which is just under 10 which is a very
good place to be here's my filing
prospectus all right
point of view you own those shares
because of who you are
i own them and people say that's
outrageous i mean why am i giving you
9.8
of the company i said because i'm mr
wonderful and you're not
50 of the time i close that deal and i
don't close it if i don't get it because
what i want is to work
hard for the next three years to build
that business up
in a way that no one else can do in a
way that no one else can do what you
guys can do
because if you're going to really trade
your
notoriety fame and followers you've got
to get paid for it
that's how you're really going to
monetize so next time you're negotiating
a deal
think of what i just said because then
then it's implicit you're going to help
them out with your notoriety and your
followers
but you're getting paid for it and
you're willing to stay the long term
now other people may listen to this say
that's outrageous kevin i said no
no it isn't you see me do it all day
long on shark tank over and over again
because i know my value i'm
confident in my value i know what i've
done you know who sells this deal to
everybody not me
it's all the ceos i invested in i said
go talk to one of my 20 30 companies
ask him if i've delivered on the value
don't take it from me talk to them
that's power you've proven yourselves by
the amount of followers you have
those are valuable in a way that so many
people
don't understand because in a consumer
goods or service businesses
which is what you guys are doing you can
say look i'm going to be transparent
i'm a huge shareholder i'm totally
transparent i own a big piece of this
company because
i believe in the product i use the
product i drink the product i eat the
product and i do
the model you gotta move to is my model
you gotta steal this idea and run with
it
you will do far better fifty percent of
the time also no
the other fifty your major shareholders
and your and their
your your alignment is total i mean
you're completely in sync with everybody
now
they'll cry about the 9.8 for one night
then you're in business so you get the
the 9.8 percent right
like what are you what are you doing
with like you're following with that
company is it like
it's not just posting and stuff right
like for us usually they just want to
like
post like you know whatever hey we're
using this or like hey here's this
article guys go check it out or like
they want us to like promote the tick
tock or the instagram so it gets
followers but like
what do you do and how do you use your
leverage well
what i do is i say look i'm a founder
now my sir aligned i want this company
be successful i've locked myself up for
years with the founder because when you
take the company out you have to tell
other shareholders look these founders
shares are not tradable
okay their founders shares and they're
locked up are going to be released
to all of us that get them over a long
period of time this is after the company
goes public even
you're not trading because your
interests are long term but i don't just
tweet and i don't just post and do
linkedin articles
i really get aggressive i hit the
airwaves
i go out there and i saw you book
meetings on you know
you're out on business cable that's cool
but you added a lot more of that
i hit every media outlet saying this
company
i'm a founder in and here's why if
you're just going to be an investor and
you're not going to use the power of
your social media
it's cool go into a round do whatever
but if you're being
a partner and you're going to use your
leverage in your platform you believe in
the product
and the mission 9.8 baby
for you your followers know that you
came from the world of business and
so they expect that from you a little
bit more for us so we almost have this
job at the same time of naturally
implementing this
and like putting it into our fans heads
in a way that's not going to be annoying
yeah but what's happening here is your
entertainment social media following is
merging
with investors interest in tapping what
you know and they don't know
you have to start thinking a little
differently because you're going to be a
player on every platform you have to be
if you're going to if you're going to
manage money you've got to be on we
talked about linkedin you talk about
these other platforms
and actually all over television radio
print
places you haven't gone yet in terms of
heavy saturation because you're
promoting
what you believe in and what you
invested in you constantly have to be
testing your assumptions
once you're running money constantly
asking yourself was i right what's
changed do i pivot
that's all going to happen to you but
you always come from a base that other
people don't have and everybody's giving
you money for one singular reason
what do they know that i don't know if
you like that video
wait did you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here
and subscribe